dernier effort de cette longue semaine
de festivités pour les sympathisants du
secours catholique
après avoir marché tout autour de l'île
c'est à la villa du département qu'ils
se sont retrouvés
avec son drapeau dans le sac rené-claude
fait partie de ces engagés m'avancer de
difficultés la difficulté est
il a alors été là dedans kamali lâché
réception parce qu'il y ait des gens est
alors voilà je suis maintenant on devait
donner ce que moi ma femme on a passé
maintenant il va donner aux gens ce que
moi
prenez donc c'est quelqu'un qui est venu
voilà qui avait envie de marcher
quelqu'un qui fait partie ce que nous on
appelle un club un groupe de personnes
qui étaient plus ou moins seuls et
isolés et je crois que ce qui a été vécu
dans ces marches cette rencontre le
regard comportait aussi les autres sur
lui positif voilà a été quelque chose
d'important ça lui a redonné confiance
en lui et je crois qu'aujourd'hui ben
j'ai envie de dire quelque part c'est
peut-être notre homme même au bout de
dix jours et qu'ils se sont remobilisés
qu'il a envie aujourd'hui de faire des
choses qu'ils envient aussi lui d'être
acteur je crois que c'est ça qui est
important c'est qu'on montre donne place
à chacun là où il en est pour qu'ils se
sentent importants et qu'ils soient
revalorisés dans ce qu'il est les
discours clôture les festivités devant
une exposition dans les salons de la
villa du département de la réunion des
scènes de vie pour raconter un esprit
qui dure depuis soixante dix ans je
dirais malheureusement l'avenir
il n'est pas
il est pas à nous dire qu'on n'aura pas
notre place je crois qu'on a notre place
on l'aura je dirais encore pour
longtemps malheureusement de dire que
effectivement la pauvreté toujours là
qu'on aura toujours accompagné à aider
les pauvres
je crois que si nous sommes importants
dans l'avenir c'est vraiment redonné
place et remettre comme acteur principal
la personne qui est en difficulté
une action toujours d'actualité qui fait
le quotidien des services du conseil
départemental
non j'ai envie de dire on le vit au
quotidien d'abord parce que nos équipes
travaillent au quotidien avec les
travailleurs sociaux principalement 90 %
des aides ou des demandes des situations
où ce envoyé par le département
je crois que c'est une vraie
collaboration dans le respect la place
de chacun pour voir comment va être plus
efficace et comment on peut aider plus
positivement les gens qui sont en
difficulté au niveau de la réunion avec
343 mille personnes vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté
cette action comme toutes celles qui
oeuvrent dans le domaine social a du
sens
mais comme on est souvent créole nous
donne la room ne râle pas charrette ans
qu'elle a besoin effectivement que tout
le monde chacun son niveau fait sa part
de son travail son engagement et les
bons de savoir quand chaque réunionnais
sommeil quelqu'un de généreux quelqu'un
de passionné pour lui-même et pour son
pays
c'est facile à dire mais maintenant plus
que jamais comme bien des tensions comme
a misé à est de plus en plus prenante
comme iliad nature et de la vie
on a tendance à se renfermer on a
tendance à ceux à s'être violents ou
alors à oublier les autres et cette
initiative la porte est ce que
catholique rappelle comme il est urgent
encore de s'ouvrir à cette tradition à
lannion d'être les gens un peuple
généreux population qui connaissent que
c'est le sens de l'entrée de la charité
nous retrouvons cela et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le département et
catholiques ont raison ensemble de faire
vivre non pas la charité mais de faire
revivre les valeurs
des gâteaux d'anniversaire de suite
partagé pour des citoyens qui se veulent
comme renée claude acteurs du mieux
vivre à la réunion